one of the things we wonder about
is does donald trump know he lost
and he's pretending to have won for
optics
or to keep raising money from his
followers or does he actually
think he is the rightful winner of the
2020 presidential election
i actually believe that may be the wrong
question people like donald trump
narcissists with delusions of grandeur
and a complete inability to self-reflect
they hold contradictory beliefs at the
same time
or sometimes they switch erratically
every 30 seconds
between one belief and its opposite cnn
is now reporting that donald trump has
told some advisors
that he is simply going to refuse to
physically leave the white house
on joe biden's inauguration day january
20th
aides report being alarmed by donald
trump saying
i'm just not leaving because as you can
imagine secret service escorting a
president out of the white house
would be fascinating but it would not
exactly do wonders
for donald trump's legacy but then after
saying i'm not leaving
trump reportedly kind of walks it back
and starts talking about who he wants to
pardon
on the way out and looking forward to
just heading down to florida seemingly
recognizing that he did lose and he will
leave
now i'm not surprised by this the
discussion about
does trump know he lost or not this is
exactly the type of thing i would expect
where one second he's insisting i'm not
going to leave because i won
and the next second he's talking about
screw this i'm out of here
i'll go play golf give me a list of
pardons to sign off on
there's nothing at all shocking or
unusual about that for someone of
trump's personality and disposition
the other funny thing is that at this
point
i believe that most of the people
convinced that trump did
actually win and joe biden stole it
recognize that unless you get some legal
determination
to overturn the election trump can't
just
sort of stay at the white house like a
squatter that that's not going to be the
way it works
i think even the people convinced trump
did win
know that unless you get some
uh a court or or a state to overturn a
result
you can't just sit at the white house
they they know even that's not going to
work and in all seriousness
i would be willing to pay money to see
donald trump dragged out by secret
service
but ultimately it's not going to happen
and trump may even end up vacating the
white house
this month there are rumors speculation
that he'll head to florida
uh around christmas or after even though
we go back and forth though trump's
going to do christmas at the white house
or maybe not we don't know
trump may leave the white house later
this month and not even come back
or maybe he will and he'll be convinced
by someone around him
you know you should really be there on
january 20th i don't know
there would be nothing better for
ratings there would be nothing better
for shock value there would be nothing
better for comedy
than trump being physically removed from
the white house but it would be a
disaster for the country and
i don't think it's actually going to
come to that now in the meantime
prepare yourselves for a flurry of
pardons
donald trump is getting endless requests
he's regularly asking people around him
should i pardon this person
should i pardon that person what about
this one people are skipping the normal
process
normally to ask for a pardon you go
through the justice department's
pardon attorney with trump everything is
insane everything is childish everything
is is unorganized
and so people are calling jared kushner
they're emailing trump's chief of staff
mark meadows
if they have a direct line to trump
they're just asking trump it's like a
feeding frenzy
of people asking for pardons and what's
interesting about that is
even though there is a formal process
for asking for a pardon in theory
anyone who knows this administration
knows that with trump
it's who can get in front of trump when
he's paying attention for 30 seconds
and maybe get him to sign off that's the
way it works and they're completely
right their instinct is exactly right
so we'll see how the pardons go but
donald trump will leave
and in preparation for trump leaving and
joe biden coming in
on january 1st we are doing a one-day
huge membership special if you've been
thinking about signing up if you are
sort of ready to make the commitment uh
to being a
member get on our mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and then on january 1st an email will go
out which will tell you
here is how to take advantage of this
borderline illegal
and certainly immoral membership special
that will be
themed based on the date it will be 1121
and the membership special will be
themed
on that basis okay uh sign up for the
newsletter
davidpakman.com on new year's day we
will let you know how to
avail yourself of that special and of
course let me know what you expect
between now and january 20th from donald
trump i'm on twitter
deepakman one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman